okay for people joining this
live stream we are talking about logic
programming
and the fundamental difference between
what we normally do
and what is usually called logic
programming
is what we normally do is you give an
input
you go crunch crunch crunch you get an
output
in logic programming you're given
a goal given a current state and a goal
potentially and you're asked how do you
get to that goal
what is the relationship between this
and things like reinforcement learning
and so on
in machine learning
do we know do we know if there's a
machine learning story around this
so i mean the the most straightforward
case
is like find string replace path where
you've given it you're given a set of
string rules and you're asked can you go
from here to there
right or find the path
now you might want you might want one
path you might want multiple paths right
you might want to know things about the
path but not actually need the path
so to what extent have we designed find
string replace path do we know all
it's all its various arguments and so on
do we know what did you understand my
question
do we do we know what questions you want
to ask about find string replace path
and how do they relate also to the
things that we do
with the multi-way system because in a
sense find string replace path
is a story related to a string multi-way
system yes
so uh you can get um the
paths in terms of states um in terms of
rules and in terms of uh rule
application positions
and you can also get the multi-wave
fragment and the
causal graph fragments for it can i see
this can i see this um
where is that documentation can i see
this somewhere
i remember yeah i'm not implementing
some of that stuff
um can you um can you tell me where it
is is it in
is it in the physics code dropbox or is
it somewhere else
uh i can put it in the physics dropbox
one no but where where is it right now
is it just in your
yeah okay so can you put it there
okay and then so in other words
this is you know fine string replace
path what we're going to talk about here
is you know you know possible
results things like is there a path
that's one question you might ask um
what are the elements on the path
what are the rules what are the events
on the path right does that make sense
yep it's in my folder in the physics
code development
okay
okay
so then we have the question of one path
or many
um
oh boy the proof object right
okay comments from people about this and
about how this relates to i mean so this
is
um there's a question what's the most
efficient algorithm for this
but this is the pure string case right
the more general case is find replace
path
what what is the algorithm for this
well i think an algorithm was some kind
of a star-ish
you know pathfinding algorithm but they
may be better okay
i mean you remember back in august when
i did that comparison against a star and
things the the
simple recursive thing that i tried
seemed to be the most efficient but i'm
wondering i'm just i'm genuinely
curious what what's the what was found
to be optimal because i haven't followed
it since well you know what i i
implemented something also and then um
rowan implemented something which i
never think never got finished
um
yeah go ahead no this was after i mean
the original thing that i designed that
you then you then added some some
syntactic stuff to i then compared
against rao and stuff and to my own
implementation of a star
and it was uh i think quadratically more
efficient
but what does it do what is it what was
it doing
so it's it's the it's the obvious divide
and conquer approach right you just say
you know you want to get from x to y uh
you don't actually have to generate the
whole multi-way system that goes from x
to y you can you can invert the rules
because they're string rules so they're
invertible
uh so you can generate a forward
multi-way system from x and a backwards
multi-way system
all right remember this but then once
you've found that
it once you've done it once you've put
in one pivot a bit like with a pivot
search or something you can actually put
in multiple
and um so you you can you can make you
can go to arbitrary recursion depth
how do you deterministically know you've
reached the right thing because i mean
if you've got two searchlights
but you know from two different places
you know that they're going to cross
somewhere
but if you have a whole chain of
searchlights you might be on the wrong
path
right right uh so so the the only the
only thing where you
the only place where it's guaranteed to
be more efficient isn't the case where
you have a single pivot
if you have multiple pivots then
effectively you have to start
you know you go to the first pivot point
and then you and then you start from
there
and you start from the middle say if
you've got three um
and it may or may not intersect with the
with the pivot point you found in which
case you move to the next pivot point
and so on
so it will it will eventually reduce to
the the one pivot case but in some
fraction of cases it will be more
efficient
okay so carlo and others so what do we
know
carlo has a summary of logic programming
languages here
yeah in terms of search i can tell you
that there is basically two main
approaches
uh prologue uses depth first uh
which means that if if it it can't get
stuck in an infinite chain
um meaning henry that's exceptionally
lame
i mean relative to what we're talking
about that's an exceptionally lame
approach
yeah but but prologue the difference is
that
here you have the goal and in prologue
enemy cannon you can generate the ball
so you don't have to give as two
so it's like give me all the possible
things
or the first 10 that you know that are
true
in this okay so this is
so just so i understand this this that
is
um okay
so it's asking like the multi-way system
um
you know so you're saying
um
it might be something like find string
replace
select or something
where where you're asking for
can you find
i.e you know can can you find
a with these rules
can you get to something which satisfies
this constraint
is that right yeah pretty much
there is a there is a difference in what
the rules look like
between prologue and mini cameron in
that the rules of prologue are horn
clauses
and so they are basically implications
and the rules in
meaning cameron are are always two-way
so
basically mini-cameron is designed we
discussed that before yeah right we
discussed the fact that
okay so so this is you know this is the
rule
types right and the rule types could be
you know either a arrow b
or a left right arrow b
right those two cases
and i understand so you're saying
um but so the cases of use
again the string case is an impoverished
case the real case of the pattern case
uh wait uh on the other hand i would
like
i think that in the case of prologue it
would be better to write it as
uh it's actually a and then the arrow
goes the other way around and then you
have b
b c d e f it means basically if b
c d e f are true then a stroke
that's usually the way it's written it's
like a
okay so then okay so there's a different
case here
which is the multi-input rules
which is something we've also
encountered in multi-way systems
right jonathan where you know this is
like
you know right last time that there's an
analogy to chemical computation and the
general problem of lemon formation
in how horn clauses are represented in
logic languages
so it's multi-input multi-way systems
which are basically saying
if i understand correctly this is which
is also known as
um branch-like you know
um what will we call them these are
these are rules that can take branch
like separated things
am i making sense it it things from
different branches
of the multi-way system can be combined
together in the rule
if i'm not mistaken
making sense because you've got all
these clauses
floating around and you can combine
multiple ones
to make the next thing right whereas in
a normal multi-way system
there's a single state and that state is
having things act on it
am i am i right
jonathan well yeah
well you're saying of course but other
people are not agreeing so
let's let's clarify do you
i mean actually i i for completely
random reasons
i implemented a little multi
multi-multi-way
system here so
this is just doing so in the multi-way
system
this is saying right here
what am i doing here multi-multi-way
system
what the heck am i asking for here
um oh i see
i see all i'm doing here i'm not
allowing um
i'm forcing one to have
two strings and i'm then looking at the
i'm i'm collecting together pairs of
strings
right and then from that
going to the next step right which is i
think what you're talking about here
with the
with the prologue case yes i mean
the classical example is like uh you
want to define a
grandparent clause then you have the
parent clause and you you're saying
basically
for a to be a grandparent of c a has to
be a grandparent
a parent of b and b a parent of c okay
question how is this related to our
sparkle query language
and is tony here that's an excellent
question uh
so usually so some of the ideas in data
log which is a constrained version
of prolong are related to
sparkle in that basically they've been
included in
the first in the sql 99 standard it's
kind of hierarchical things
so it's it's called recursive width and
so basically for example
you wanna imagine you have a database
with a bunch of people
and their managers and you wanna know
basically who's
the ceo who's the manager yeah something
like that
uh impossible to to uh
represent in older versions of sql um
okay but so how is this related
um okay
how is this related to sparkle how is
what we're talking about so in other
words
the the chain of connections right
sparkle
allows you to do we have tony here
he's not here now could you please try
and see if you can find him yeah
did you find roger or not
he has not responded to the request okay
michael do you have any comments on
sparkle relationship here
no i'm not enough of an expert other
than like the sparkle is more kind of
you have legal fragments you don't have
so much the big picture in mind
but but in sparkle if you look at things
like sparkle property path
it's exactly that if you put a pattern
in the sparkle property path
basically you can do hierarchical rules
and
recursive rules um right an rdf
triple is a fragment
of one of these it's it's
okay so
in a sense what is the relationship okay
so
relation to sparkle the question is
the relation to sparkle is actually
there are languages where it's clearer
than sparkle and
um there is a another version of
semantic web
that is actually based on data log um
which is called something like intellidb
or something like that
uh but basically the the whole idea of
uh i wanna know whether
you know you wanna compute something
that has an arbitrary number of steps in
it
that's the relation it's the yeah i
understand the transitive closure of
relational algebra basically
okay i understand so this is very
category theory like also
i mean it's very like these are
morphisms and we're looking at
um well i don't know morphisms have a
built-in transitive closure idea
to them whereas these do not but what
you're saying is
we can imagine fragments just like okay
so the generalization of string replace
path would be
that we have multi-element string rules
right and that we're basically matching
against those
we're saying is there a path
that can be formed uh
from these rdf triples
i'm not entirely sure that you can do it
with strings because strings are
are inherently you know strings so you
can take something from the beginning of
the string and something from the end of
the string on the other hand this kind
of
uh rule systems have a set
of i i i'm aware i'm aware i'm aware i'm
aware
i'm i'm i'm making the we're using
strings
one gulp at a time we're not breaking
the strings into pieces in this case
do you see what i'm saying so this would
be this would be whole string
if it was strings it's whole object
slash
whole string
transformations do you get what i'm
saying
yeah right so whereas a string you're
expecting to do sub strings
as opposed to substrings which i think
is different
from the sparkle case see what i'm
saying
in the sparkle case you're dealing with
these
you know you're dealing with a whole
collection of complete strings
which have transformations between them
um maybe
maybe my logic knowledge is impaired
why is a horn clause based declarative
prover any different from a global
string multi-way system
you're dealing with things from you know
opposite ends of branchfield space there
okay let's try and unpack that statement
let's first of all remember what a local
multi-way system is
there are these things that i invented
that no one seemed to show any
enthusiasm for which i think they're
great
but which are uh string multi-way
systems where you effectively shatter
the string
into um into each element of the
alphabet
for that for the substitution system and
you have so this
so each event operates on branch-like
separated characters
but the events themselves have
isomorphism testing
which i thought at least at the time was
equivalent to a declarative horn clause
based prover
that was part of the reason for building
it but could be maybe i don't know
i i don't know it could very well be
okay so hold on hold on
so the claim is glocal multi-way systems
question mark
a world of horn clauses
um it sounds plausible
i mean what what implication so so that
would be
saying that what you'd be doing is i.e
i.e what we want i.e we would need
uh find string replace path
in a local multi-way system rather than
an ordinary multi-base system how would
you
how would you formulate that so stephen
i just sent you a picture of what i mean
i mean the the global multi-way code is
not yet
wfred but okay you sent it an email or
yes okay
uh question in the meantime so by
you're using the adjective glocal so it
has properties of
global and local systems
exactly so it has the property of local
multi-way systems that
inputs for events can come from
branch-like or space-like separated
places but it has the property of global
multi-way systems that the
events are merged on the basis of some
isomorphism testing
sorry say that again jonathan so wait a
minute you've shattered the string here
right into a b right and so you can see
there that the first
event is ingesting one a and one b which
is why you have two arrows going in one
from the a1 from the b
and it's outputting two a's and a b
which is why you see two arrows coming
out and connecting to the a
and one arrow coming out connecting to
the b
right oh i see after those
right i get it after that why those are
in sequence i don't really know
because normally in a multi-way system
there is no sequencing the fact that
this is a bba
sequence is more information than a
multiple multi-wave system usually just
has a bunch of states in it
it's not same there's no there's no
sequencing here either
oh so then this is just counting the
number of a's and b's
in effect yes okay so so these are
these are strings in name only they're
they're they're commutative strings
effectively
is that correct no because because the i
mean you could treat them that way if
you only looked at the states but if but
the events still have all the structure
that you care about
if you get out the causal graph for this
right and yeah and you just look at the
event structure it still has everything
that a global model
the reason i constructed it was
precisely because the events encoder
global multi-evolution and the
states encode a local multi-way
evolution so
so the reason it's called a global
multi-weight system as kind of as jan
i guess pointed out was that actually
all the information to construct either
a global or a local multi-multi-way
evolution is contained in this one
object
um i don't really understand the subject
yet
so the order matters this a b the order
matters
is that true but it matters in the event
because the the structure of the event i
can see it matters in the event but i
mean
these things effectively have additional
tagging not visible to us
that says that b state is a
b7 state that must be in this position
type thing
right right i mean you can enforce the
property the concatenation is
commutative if you want and and actually
i mean i have examples where i did that
but this is one where it isn't
right i'm sorry i just have a
bizarre problem here just a second
what on earth is this doing
um help just a second
um hold on a second uh
oh gosh this is really stupid
um
okay maybe this will work
who knows okay all right
i'm sorry my only reason for bringing
this up is just that
uh at least from my understanding this
is formally equivalent
you know having a rule that says b goes
to a b is formally equivalent now to a
rule i mean
that's actually stronger than a horn
clause because it's saying b goes to
a and b which is not normally how you
define it but
um you would split that up into two
rules one saying b goes to a1 saying b
goes to
b goes to b but the point is because you
can have multiple
input characters that at least that
component of the rule structure
simulates a horn clause wait a minute so
i don't yet understand how a local
multi-wave system
with a multi multi-element string on the
left works
because i hadn't realized that this is
um
um
right i hadn't realized this just has
this is
as somebody called it at one point
monogenic it has a single
it's a neighbor independent set up here
right but but actually that doesn't
matter i mean even
even if the rule there where a b goes to
a b the the edge structure would look
the same
it would still have how does it know
what the order of the a b is
at the level of a state how does it know
the ordering you know
that can be i mean if it doesn't have
a if it doesn't have a commutativity
axiom then the order is known because
the
the events the events know the global
states
okay fine but then yeah okay but so then
this picture is somewhat misleading
because the actual
the order in which these states occur
here
matters no i don't think the picture is
misleading
the events show that the order matters
and the states show
what happens if the order doesn't matter
that's why the events form a global
system and the
states form a local system
if you just viewed the states graph it
would be a local multi-way system where
the order didn't matter because it
wouldn't
in a sense it wouldn't matter whether a
b was going in or b a was going in
yeah just show the events it's a global
multi-wave system where it absolutely
does matter
and the point is that then the evolution
events graph which is what this is
showing
has both pieces so you can principalize
either multi-way system from this object
right but but so our the relevance to
this is as we're looking for
you know this idea of what is logic
programming right what we're realizing
is
there are these different cases there
are questions like that okay so another
rule type is a multi-input
multi-input rules right that's a case we
haven't considered here this is a case
where we say
um you know where you have to have both
a together with when it's some weird
symbol here
you know together with b and
it's usually end it's uh i mean it's an
implied
uh conjunction yeah i i realize that
right i mean i'm so
i mean i don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna
draw it in some decorative way
okay um well sometimes often they're
just commas
right yeah in in logic programming there
are commas
in logic logic it's uh you know upside
down v
yeah right yeah fine but i'm just saying
these things are present in some bag of
things that
are present just like here the certain
states are present
and then events can happen on those
states so this is saying certain events
certain
strings are present it's the same thing
in sparkle certain things are present we
can combine them in these ways
right yeah and and usually a and b
can contain blanks uh
that then appear in c they're captured
in c yeah i get it i get it right but i
mean
but the the difference between that and
find string replace path
is fine string replace path is going
into
sub elements of
so what i'm saying in sub elements of a
and b to do things
same with finds find replace path is
taking a series of expressions
a single expression here and saying how
do i use
a rule that can go into the sub to
sub-expressions
okay this makes sense so it's the
difference between branch-like and
tree-like
rules i claim so find replace path is
still doing
its quotes tree-like rules
unless it has multi-input in which case
it's branch-like
does that make sense jonathan does that
make sense to you
yeah but again i i'm i'm i'm trying to
figure out why is this
why is the string replaced why is the
replace path case of this any different
from doing the recursive replace path
algorithm we described earlier
just with a global multi-way system with
wild card characters
it might not be i'm just not there yet
but it might not be right and that might
be the
most general case but the thing i'm
trying to understand first is
we've got several different things
running around right we've got
we've got several things we want to do
like you know
given the path and maybe sparkle is
parameterizing some of that as well
you know what are the elements on the
path i mean let's look at some of this
um
okay so this is
wild cards on a path right this is
finding
a path with wild cards on it
test whether a query pattern matches
that's is there a path
right limit the number of solutions okay
what is an aggregate
oh boy that is a way of doing of
multiple paths
i think this is a way of counting this
is a path counting thing
well well aggregate is here is the same
thing as the sql aggregates so it's
things like mean count mean max
uh string join yeah i get it but
in terms of paths that's a path counting
story isn't it
can be used for that but it's not just
that i mean
you can use it to ask things like how
many generations do you have to go back
in that case it's counting path but you
can also ask
how many children do they have in that
case it's not
in the path it's counting the leaves
it's i mean aggregate
is really in in general in in relational
algebra it's something that takes uh
something that is vector-like and turns
with something that is a is a scalar
yeah right um
i mean another thing that we might be
able to do is return tree objects return
graph objects from
finds you know this is okay so
um we can certainly return graph objects
return graph for
a multi-way graph fragment
yeah right now i noticed that um
okay all right so this is the sparkle
story here so
let's go back to and again we haven't
yet understood
i haven't yet understood jonathan's
gokul stuff
okay so that's still on the shelf here
but i'm trying to understand what is the
most
general kind of question that we're
trying to answer and then how do we
break that down into simpler versions so
so this case here
this case here is not a traditional
pattern matching case for us
right the case sparkle
in principle can be done
by our pattern matching i think
is that a true statement we're finding
these paths
and it is very much like in in the whole
physics project
we're simply finding does there exist
you know the sparkle thing is ultimately
a hypograph is it not
uh this yeah it is it's uh
yeah it is a hyper graph and uh
it can be done with the pattern matching
in basically with replace repeated
or replace list i mean it's it's both
really replace repeated and replace list
because it finds all possible right but
it's also related to tony's
subset replace
yeah sure right that's another
i mean this is okay so there's a
relation to
yeah it's because in general they are
they are unordered
but all the clauses are in order all the
relations are in order
right so subset cases would be the thing
that finds
kind of the i mean that's that's how
subset cases is built
which which is the internal
implementation of of multi-way system
right model thing and obviously
in that case you you have commutativity
anyway precisely for this reason because
because you have an unordered set
so then actually the local multi-way
system becomes much more natural
which means i have to understand it oh
well the
okay but let's let's go back here
um
okay so let's go back to the logic
programming
stuff here okay so this is based on horn
clauses
all right so then the the basic question
that is being answered is
here are a bunch of uh essentially
implication fragments can these be
knitted together to make a path from
here to there
is that true
yeah or or the other case which
you call fine swing play select is
what are what are the the things that
you can produce with this
give me the first 10 you can produce or
something like that
but satisfying constraint or okay
which is basically well that idea is
used much more powerfully
in many canon-like systems as they can
be used to
i mean if you have a small enough
language that you can basically invert
then you can ask it to build wines
and other interesting animals
and and many canadians can do the mixed
case as well right which i think also
is not a general feature where you can
give it you can specify a partial goal
and a partial
set of implications and it will fill in
bits yeah i mean meaning karen
basically at the end it has a
unification but also a reification
uh passage and so it basically can
reconstruct new
variables that are basically uh
not quantified right so they're not
uni520
but i remember when i was when i was
looking into like alien tap which is the
this declarative theorem improver built
on top of mini caneron
it could do the if you give it a
if you give it a theorem it could find
the proof which is the path counting but
you know the path finding case
and if you gave it a proof it could tell
you the theorem which is the
checking case that's the endpoint case
but it could also have a you could also
specify an incomplete theorem
and an incomplete proof and it would
fill in possible details
which is kind of the intermediate case
yeah
and yeah and you can also basically
generate
all programs that have a certain thing
a certain characteristic okay so that
you could say
um you know one case apparently you're
saying
is a partial theorem
plus partial proof right
right what can be filled in you specify
part of the endpoints
and part of the set of input of the
total set of implications and you ask
what's the yeah what are the consistent
sets of things that could be right
so this is essentially a cases game this
is some generalized cases
it's asking what
i think maybe it isn't maybe it's a
generalized
some kind of generalized subset cases or
something
not quite sure um
okay so the more obvious theorem proving
case is
uh the more obvious they're improving is
like find
replace path you know i.e
find a proof going from a to b
except that's not
see that that's not the case that's not
the multi-input case
right that's not the case that we've
discussed
you know am i making sense that that's
not
there's another case which is i don't
see what the
i i don't know maybe there's some
complexity i'm missing i don't see what
the issue is right it's
you've got it you know in the language
of multi-way systems you've got
a sub-branchio graph to sub-branch your
graph input
in which you give essentially a
collection of paths that's one
that's the their improving case right
you've got the collection of paths what
are the what are the sub
what are the possible branchial graphs
that are consistent with those paths
that you know where where the endpoints
form sub-branchial graphs that are
consistent with those paths
that's the proof checking case the
inverse and then you've got the case
where you specify
maybe some parts or partial sections of
paths and partial specifications of
branch
of sub-branch or graphs and you ask what
you know
what right this is all
sensible okay here's here's the unfair
part of the situation right
all this stuff with branchographs and
multi-way systems and so on this is all
just being invented in the past year
right so the ability to unify this whole
story
in terms of those things is kind of a
you you make it sound obvious
but it's in a sense that obviousness is
is rather recent fair
and it's lost on me totally for example
yeah well right because
this is a new way of thinking about
these kinds of things and it's a very
nice unified way of thinking about them
and it's one that we you know it's one
that gives us the opportunity finally to
do logic programming like things
in an organized way because it it
unifies
all these different cases of of this and
that and which is what jonathan is
basically saying
fair jonathan i i think so but i mean
i don't think the ideas of that i mean
yeah the the vocabulary for reasoning
about things
reasoning about them is new but you know
in a sense that's what logic programming
languages like mini cameron have been
doing implicitly
oh yeah implicitly for millions of years
right
the thing is that they haven't seen
pictures of actual multi-way systems
they don't have the notion of events i
mean they do have the notion of events
but they don't talk about them that way
um i mean i i just think this is
yes i mean this is a sort of a grand
unification thing
and it's also i don't think the world of
sparkle is that close to the world of
logic programming usually
it should be but it isn't it's a it's a
it's a much smaller subset it's uh the
data log is the
the the connection so data log is it's
basically a non-true incomplete version
of prolog
that doesn't have basically the
expressions are much simpler
you can't have arbitrary nesting in the
expression and
and basically that's where they got the
ideas
that led to the transitive closure of
sql
and then okay so so what is z3 i mean
i've certainly heard of it for millions
of years but
okay so z3 is one one of the most
powerful of a family of
smt solvers smt means uh satisfiability
multiple theory
and so it's like sat the kook one
but uh we with extra stuff not just
boolean variables
and it's very fast very powerful
there are links to many languages
i think i mean okay so what is it doing
so so i mean right now we have
you know we have satisfiable q for
boolean expressions that's quite
efficient
it uses a pretty good sat solver right
so explain to me what an smt solver is
relative to a boolean expression sat
solver
uh okay so uh boolean expression set
solver only knows about
boolean variables and so all the things
that appear
so you you have all the variables that
appear are increasingly boolean
in an smt solver depending on what
theories you can you put in it
you can teach it about integers you can
teach about strings
and and so on and so forth and so
basically i don't know so what go ahead
what
what's the
um explain to me
what is the definition of um
yeah i just i just don't know what um uh
why don't you click on that hyperlink uh
it's probably that that hyperlink
explains it better than i
can never because then it depends a lot
on on what
uh smt solver you're dealing with
because different destinies holders have
different theories
okay it says by example here so
let me see an example of one of these
so one thing we could do obviously is to
connect this
to what we have but what is this doing
what is this doing
that looks like algebra which seems like
a
very wrong thing to do this with
anybody know what this is doing
okay carlo do you know what this is
doing
uh i don't know exactly that one but
i played a little bit with s3 um
and uh i mean you can use it
it's a bit complicated to explain
because you can you can use it
as a theorem proverb basically and so
you can you can
exactly why these people have removed
the in-out symbols okay so they're using
satisfy but okay so at least this is
i understand this is similar to
right
i mean as i understand it these are all
just specifications of predicate logic
statements
ultimately okay as opposed to
propositional logic for a standard
sat solver right so if you took a sat
problem and you replaced what would have
been you know
boolean variables with boolean uh
elements
and you replace them with predicates
that are quantified over some set of
non-boolean variables
then you get an smt solver so you can
have some
that have lists some have strings some
have
numbers you can basically do the same
kind of thing you do with a set solder
over numbers over strings
so okay but but by that as well
okay but so what is the relationship
between that so
is this like in in multi-way systems for
example
we can have this idea of essentially a
reverse multi-way system in which you
have a soup of lemmas
and you're trying to combine them to get
to true is that the same kind of thing
that you're doing here
yeah i would say yes
okay so
again i'm i'm trying to understand how
to
okay so what what we basically want to
achieve
is like for example
this concept find replace path it's a
very clean
concept right i really understand this
concept
right it's just you're given a set of
rules and you say how do you get from
here to here
it's very easy to understand that
concept
so similarly i mean what we're trying to
do is we're trying to unify
these sort of the many tentacles of
logic programming
into a small set of concepts like this
where then we can go underneath it
and actually potentially have different
implementations for different
particular things you're trying to get
out
that makes sense so
and our use case i mean honestly the
sparkle system that we have other than
the few sparkle endpoints that exist in
the world which it's fun to
to use i don't think we've had much use
yet for our sparkle system
that doesn't seem to be a thing that's
showing up very much
i mean we've got our own version of
something like that in the
in the surf framework for or from alpha
but it's not specifically using sparkle
it's using our own
stuff that's optimized in different ways
i mean i think one of the problems with
sparkle is that
i mean there is a very steep learning
curve
especially if you want to build your own
set of truths out there so sparkle you
can only use with
things that are already existing more or
less so like
otherwise you have to set up server and
start well i know i mean like for
example we're using wiki data you know
we have wikidata data
which is using that sparkle endpoint
um but the sparkle queries you can do i
don't think people are mostly doing very
sophisticated sparkle queries against it
look the use cases that we've discussed
i mean the the pure path use cases
are things like you know
like game trees like chemical reactions
um like the visualization pipeline
you know like like that would be an
example can you get to
given this set of data can you
make a histogram out of it yup
and there's stuff like for example code
simplification and optimization
how how how so for example in closure
they have this thing called core logic
that does that
basically you can tell that two
snippets of code are equivalent by
feeding the transformations
the problem yeah we've done many
experiments with that
they have they've been rather
unsuccessful yeah
i think that one big big hurdle for for
us
is that in the case of meaning cameron
they are effectively
since they start from scheme which is
very small language
they can they basically can write the
eval
lisp thing in a way that is reversible
because the whole language can be
written in a reversible way
think about something like a pen no no
no i understand i understand
look we've we have written we have
collected a large number of theorems
code equivalence theorems
right
and you know
i agree that that's a
i mean look simplification is another
version of this
where we have the same exact type of
thing
and remember also the thing i was
talking about a week ago or something
this obstructions framework
where you're doing simplification so i
there's another question here relation
to the obstructions framework
right so you remember the obstructions
framework the obstructions framework is
you are getting to a certain point and
if only you could assume that this was
an integer
everything becomes easy right but you're
not assuming that so it becomes this
very complicated thing
and how do you provide a mechanism
where you can easily say there is a path
it just requires this one assumption
um right marco on a live stream is
commenting that
yes this smt idea is
basically using data structures to
simplify search base and so on okay so
look our main challenge here
is to package this stuff in a way that's
actually useful right and i i
claim that find replace path
is an easy to understand and somewhat
useful thing what do other people think
about that
right so imagine if you're doing
codes code equivalence okay so you're
saying there is a notion
i mean there's a okay so find replace
path select bad names might be for
things like
eg uh simplification right so
with simplification you're given a
collection of rules and you're told
yeah you see that that's more of an
optimization problem right
well it depends on how if you want if
you have a
like in simplify you have a kind of a
weight system that tells you this is
simpler
otherwise this stuff can be used to
generate sometimes infinitely many
equivalent expressions
no i understand but i mean absolutely
like a multi-way system
i mean a multi-way system is just you're
applying these transformations in all
possible ways you get this whole
network it has many mergers and branches
and we've got a whole theory of mergers
and branches
et cetera et cetera et cetera but this
is i mean
you know let's see what will be there
should be called find replace buff
to me it's not it's something like
replace repeated list
something like that and then cases
no but i think what it is is is find
replace
objective as in simplify so so
look they're different um i'm gonna have
to go soon but but um
there are this is very interesting i
mean look look
this is a sort of grand unification
opportunity
um we're not there yet but
right so so this is a case where
basically you are given
you know find replace subjective might
be given okay you've got
this rule you can use a part you can use
together
you can use i don't know um
some other random rule you know blah
blah blah goes to blah blah blah
um or i can write this as a rule
x blank goes to a part of x
and so on right these are all
do you see what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah absolutely um
and uh you know what is that what the
objective look like
i would say um the objective could be
um leaf count you know so so
find replace i mean
look actually this is more like find
replace maximize
or minimize or whatever you know minus
leaf count whatever it is
find replace minimize whatever so then
this is
actually this is more like find replace
objective by
by leaf count
i'm not sure about find replace by
what's what's the underlying so what
would be the underlying thing without
the objective so like
generate them all yeah i think so
generate 10
what would that be called i don't know
i don't know but i mean what this
essentially is doing and this relates
very closely to the design of multi-wave
system
which the multi look what is the
difference between these things and
multi-way system
answer multi-way system is a big gulp
it's generating the whole thing
the whole graph of all these
transformations right
and we're we're doing things with that
whole graph whereas
these functions are all dealing with
path through the graph
counting pieces of the graph and so on
does that make sense
yeah and i i think i mean i think we
should
make make make clear the way this works
in terms of uh
whether it's to replace all replace zero
infinity
or replace the whole thing level one uh
level zero sorry
see i mean we're planning to actually
have multi-way system be a system
function
okay so um you know
much of what we're doing
is is you know finding subparts of the
multi-way graph
right so the multi-way graph you know it
is
it is sort of our new activity because
we think it relates to physics among
other things
to kind of look at the whole multi-graph
as opposed to all these other things
where people are like i'm afraid of the
whole multi-way graph let me just try
and find a path
that makes sense well one thing
one thing that i would like to talk
about if we managed to have another
meeting about this
is also um pattern unification
so what it means to have a two-way
pattern with blanks on both sides
yes i know that's the thing we need
actually this thing that i found this
sat thing by example is quite useful
because it has a lot of wall from
language stuff
in it and it shows kind of how this this
seems useful this seems something that's
worth us
us reading um
can we have it like can you
put it somewhere
lou is asking why is there a fine before
find replace path yeah it's a good
question it probably shouldn't be i mean
usually we put a find before something
um
to um
to indicate that that it is not
guaranteed to
to get there is the the final the that
there isn't a unique
thing that is just fine seek you know
uh uh and it's not guaranteed
like fine minimum doesn't guarantee to
actually
it will do its best it will go search
for a minimum but it doesn't necessarily
reach it
um let me just i think in this case it's
more like the difference between
replace and replace list right
well replace does replace list is giving
you the
the spray out at a particular node in
the multi-way graph
it's giving you the possible things that
can happen it's not
giving you a path through the graph it's
it's yeah i don't replace it but what
i'm saying is that
with respect like the difference with
the find functions
like find minimum and so on is that this
guy is
possibly finding all of them you can
tell to halt after 1910
but it's it's probably going to return a
list unless you have a
minimizer version of it
um yeah lou is commenting on the the
does replace multiply fine first
no because this is a different thing
this is saying
you're finding a path rather than doing
the individual replacements
um yeah marco is saying you're basically
finding path and see all possible
computations that's that's correct
um and first he's commenting you can't
be sure they're global minima other than
brute force well sometimes you can
that's what you know
there are cases in which you can prove
the theorem that you've got
quotes the minimum um and that's those
guys
these algorithms are all brute force
really smart brute force but brute force
i understand what one can make certain
um and jonathan is commenting that this
is all related to the expresso power
non-deterministic turing machines
yes i mean this this is the story i mean
in a sense
a multi-way system is a packaging of
non-determinism
right but specifically when you were
talking about applications
this seems like an obvious one
you mean everything that's an np problem
no no i mean proving theorems about the
expressive power of ndtms which is
otherwise hard to do
if you if you want to prove you know
universality of a of an ordinary
deterministic
turing machine that's just a single you
know single origin point single endpoint
find path problem
yes uh but in this case where you want
an extended you know
branch-like sub-graph to branch like
sub-graph
and you're finding a collection of pods
or you want to know if there exists a
collection of paths between the two
that's an expressive that's a statement
i'm glad you're giving an ad for the
thing that i just posted about three
days ago
for yes i agree it's hard i tried to do
this i
it's i mean this this is a story of
multi-way touring machines right
and it's the story of what you know
when one multi-way turing machine can
represent others and so on and what
possible paths there are
that can be found in them yes i mean
this
this was a kind of a multi-way
exploration of that as opposed to
i mean which i think is the most yeah
are you making a different point yes
a completely different point so okay um
the the problem that you
i think first came to me with i noticed
it didn't make it into the bulletin
but this point that if you construct a
global multi-way system
for a turing machine which i've done um
then this question of what is the what
is the encoding of a particular state
of an ndtm you can effectively express
as a as a branchially extended tape
state
right yes which you otherwise couldn't
do in a global multi-way system which is
what my old code which you're using here
is doing right
well you're saying that there is a way
of representing
a collection of of ndtm states
as a branchly extended object i agree
no a single ndtm state is a as a what
what do we mean by ndtm state we mean do
we mean one of the states here or do we
mean
a state that is obtained by looking at
this whole
step well i mean a state of the ndtm
which is a superposition of
classification okay
fine okay fine that's what you mean by a
state
right let's take the ndtn
as opposed to a state of the underlying
turing machine which has now become
non-deterministic
right um
right okay and so then what were you
saying
well the point is if you construct the
global analog of that right so
you so each each position on the tape is
now a single object on a branch like
hypersurface
then exactly the same problem that mini
cameron is solving
is the problem of determining can i
evolve from a particular ndtm tape state
to a different ndtm
tape state which which dramatically
simplifies the problem of of proving say
universality results of ndtms
because it makes it much closer to the
classical tm type argument
you're saying consider
a lump of branchial space
and ask can you get from one lump of so
we have pictures someplace here
of pieces of bronchial space
so
you're saying
does there exist a path to get from one
place i'm not quite sure what you're
saying
so so the so my multi-way touring
machine function if you if you generate
the branchial graphs from that which i
think is what you're doing here
you get mobile multi-way states right
which is very far removed from how you
would express the state of a single
classical turing machine
that's true right the expression in
order to get it closer what you want is
something analogous to the tape state
and the head state of a single classical
turing machine that's true
which is exactly what you would get if
you took each
position on the tape and had it occupy a
different point in branchial space and
had events that are operated on those
in other words if you had a global
multi-way representation of this
right um
say that again i'm sorry there um
say it again sorry i've got distracted
position and you have it occupies
a separate position in bronchial space
or just be a separate node in the
branchial graph
right then that's much cl then you have
a representation that's much closer to
that of an ordinary
classical turing machine you have a tape
a single tape a single head
that happens to be branchially extended
but that kind of doesn't matter
right what wait a minute the tape
is in branchial space or what
i'm confused i'm completely confused
here okay so
the formal definition of what a global
multi-wave system is right is
you take whatever the state is you
decompose it into its character set and
you have each element of the character
set occupy a different vertex in the
branchio graph
and then the rules don't operate on
states they operate on
subsets of characters that can be
localized or non-localized
that's the fundamental distinction
localized in so are you thinking of this
gokul
system as being transformations on
branchial graphs can you think of it
that way
of course that's that's why it relates
to the whole mini camera that was the
point i was making right that it's
when you when you say here's a
collection of propositions here's and
here's another collection of
propositions you want to get
from one to the other you're finding a
collection of paths that map from one
subhyper graph to one sub
one sub graph of a bronchograph to
another subgraph from a branchio graph
with rules that are haunted clauses that
act on sub-branchial graphs
which is very different from the global
multi-way case right
i understand so the claim is okay so
first of all for other people's benefit
here i mean these branchial graphs are a
map
of state space that are mapped by common
ancestry of state space
um so go ahead what are you going to say
so
if you construct the global analog of
this each character which in which in
our case
is going to be a single a single tape
state position
occupies a single vertex
just like in any other global multi-way
system
right well each wait a minute given a
tape configuration there are two issues
in a turing machine
there's the tape configuration and
there's the position of the head
and the state of the head and the state
of the head yes i mean i've been
considering a lot of state
one-state touring machines so that
doesn't really matter there right but
but in my in the in my multi-way turing
machine implementation
the the the tape states in the head
state are effectively treated
they are essentially concatenated and
treated as a single kind of
thing you can do substitutions on right
yes right so all i'm saying is apply the
procedure i just said but to the case
during machines
sorry which procedure i mean so we've
got a tape you take the character set
and you have each element of the
character set occupy a single point in
the branch your graph
so in that each so each
element each each element on the tape
at a particular position
which is not what you're doing with the
strings or were you doing that with the
strings
yeah that was the okay but but but then
what you're saying is
for the turing machine okay let's go
back to a friendly touring that's why
with the strings you know
there were two separate global strings a
b and b a but they occupied four points
in branchial space
okay fine but then they were tagged so
in other words we're saying
this particular position on the tape
which is position 13 or something on the
tape there's no tagging this is as
i mentioned that this is just
interpreted from the event history
there's no additional information beyond
what you already see in the evolution
events graph
what you're describing as tagging is
just a statement about event ancestry
which is already
part of the system
okay but but it to make me less confused
let's imagine we tagged all
of these so this thing has been
shattered into something that says
uh you know cell 13 is white
right i've got a whole bag of those
things cell 13 is white cell 13 is
orange whatever
and then then my branchial connection
collection
is something which has both
you know unambiguous cell 13 is white
and ambiguous cell 13 could be white or
it could be orange
is that true where i where i have two
points
yeah but the point is that in the local
setup you don't make any distinction
between that but
the whole point of that formalism is you
don't make a distinction between
separation on the tape and separation in
bronchial space
there are just separations and the only
and the tagging
occurs because of event ancestry because
the events operate globally
just like they do in multi-way systems
yes i understand i mean what you're
doing is you're knitting the things
together
by virtue of their event ancestry right
in which case the as i said the the
problem of proving expressive power of
an ndtm becomes
the same as the problem you would solve
for the logic programming language which
is not certainly not true in the global
case
well that's cool
that's cool maybe the the um
i think that's highly relevant to what
we thought we were going to do our
physics live stream about so we've
we've now made a grand grand unification
of um
i mean i don't fully understand this yet
but
but is it your claim
okay there's a big there's a piece to
what we're doing here which has to do
with
patterns for expressions and things like
this
um right which is the multi-way operator
form of the same thing
indeed which again already exists
i mean it already exists you mean you
wrote it yeah
you wrote the multi-way system case of
that
right well there's the multi-way there's
the global multi-way and the recursive
finding case for multi-way operator
systems yeah
what what did you call them the
recursive finding case
uh it's not it's not in the function
repository because i thought someone
else was taking over the
find replay i thought mano was taking
over the find replace project but
okay but but you're but you claim it as
a part of the find replace path
family well the recursive algorithm i
described
doesn't care what the system is it just
cares that you have a multi-way
structure
right all it's doing is it's finding
intersections between forward and
backward
i get it yeah i get it so it does so
because multi-way operating system does
pattern unification internally anyway
that code is trivial i mean the code to
actually do the pathfinding is true okay
but the pattern unification part
that's a separate issue which is two-way
patterns right
so i mean this is this is another thing
is two-way patterns right which we don't
have right now
right so two way pattern is something of
the form you know
f of x blank you know
g of y blank um
two-way arrow
h of x blank you know why blank
something or other
right and and obviously the way we get
around that in both fine equation or
proof and in multi-way operator system
is by paramodulating
but we can undoubtedly there's a more
elegant way of dealing with it
what is the paramodulation operation
again
so that's where we this is the operation
in superpositional calculus where you
just
convert you convert bi-directional
equations into unidirectional rules
so in that case where you have if you
have a two-way pattern rule you can
convert it into a pair of
single-way pattern rules where there are
only patterns on one side
i see that's what the fair modulation
operation allows you to do
well so so
so why don't we have a function called
paramodulate
uh that's a good question we probably
should
so which would take a two-way rule like
this and we could imagine
you know paramodulate that two-way rule
and it would give us a pair of one-way
rules is that right
yes right is it obvious what that what
that pair of one-way rules would be in
this case i mean is it is it
uh when there's over because you have
overlap of the
um in the case we okay this case it's
quite easy because you don't have
overlap of the non-variable subterms
so you don't actually have to unify
anything right but if i
did that i would probably have a more
complicated story
yeah that would that would be tricky and
it would be more tricky if you had uh
say a g
on both an operator g on both sides
i see um that then that's
that's the case where you'd have to
compute mgus but without that you
effectively just say you know you have
x pattern y pattern you know x pattern
equals y pattern you just convert that
into a
uh x pattern goes to y literal
and a uh and a y pattern goes to x
literal
so here's an embarrassing admission
okay in the last third of a century so
the way our pattern
assignment system works right it will
try to put
more general patterns after more special
patterns right so if i say f of x blank
equals blah and then i say f of one
equals blah it puts the f of one in
front of the f of x blank
right and one of the things that we
you know i spent a bunch of time
worrying about when we first set that
system up
um actually that system was even built
for smp but but anyway
the the um when i first set that system
up i worried about this question of in
what order do you really put patterns in
right because in general two patterns do
not have
a one is contained in the other
relationship
okay and so in a perfect world the right
way to do this is with unifiers
i think that is given two patterns
you know what we want to do is we want
to say
you know
i mean the question is what is the right
way
do you understand the question
that everybody know other people
can you know this is do do you
understand the issue here
um
anybody understand the issue i think i
do
so you're asking it's the problem of
ordering uh
down values basically yes it's a problem
of ordering down values
right and what do you do for example let
me say i have a
a down value that says f of x blank
semicolon prime q of x
and then i say f x
blank you know slash go back conjecture
you know whatever it is some some kind
of something i know this is a bad
example but i mean
you know some kind of go back something
or other thing here
right what order that's a bad example
but but you know what order do i put
these in
see what i'm saying one of them is
unknown generality relative to the other
one
right is there a consistent ordering
answer no which is why we punted on that
issue
but in simple cases we do it in more
complicated cases we don't
it turns out that it's just fine in
practice
because as soon as it gets complicated
you know
as soon as it gets complicated you
typically don't do that by using the
automated
pattern rule but i think that there's a
this whole question about
general unifiers and so on is what you
need in order to
address this question
uh for these many instances of two-way
rules
no actually two-way rules are pretty
rare we only introduced the two-way rule
construct very recently
and that two-way rule construct is um
uh you know it look for example graphs
undirected graphs it's useful
and um oh yeah here's a really weird
example which is transpose it's a useful
way to represent that
sorry go ahead what were you going to
say i was going to say but
isn't this uh provably uh
undecidable of course yeah okay
of course it is because because when i
when i
wrote the the wall from language
implementation of encounter i basically
uh decided that the only way i mean
the main problem is condition once you
have condition
you kind of have to punt
i mean the condition could actually be
effective and what not
so if you if you're using just straight
patterns
you can kind of unify them you can
define a way to find them right
well by the way what happened to your
mini canon implementation
oh you have it something we can put in
the function repository
uh no we haven't
does it have a smallish number of
functions or is it a big a big
thing with with 65 tentacles uh
i mean the point is that that for it to
actually be useful i mean there is a
micro version of it
micro camera which can be written in a
small but it's important
to use unless you start writing uh
the what they call in the book the
bizarre word
version of normal function otherwise you
can't do much with it
okay well all right listen we should
wrap this
this meeting up um and uh
uh actually bizarrely the topic that
jonathan and i were planning to talk
about in
our physics working session is is
bizarrely related to all of this
um in a in a just wasn't intended at all
um but i think it's very related um
okay we better wrap for for here
um oh nick is saying has a function that
kind of converts a rule into a two-way
rule replaces all left-bound pattern
variables
some careful treatment of pattern tests
and conditions that's interesting
i mean i think this is a yeah i mean
it's a problem we have not run into very
much but it's something
clearly for the theorem prover this is
highly relevant this two-way
pattern thing is highly relevant i mean
jonathan if we
if we had properly handled two-way
pattern things
what would that do to find equational
proof could we generalize that in an
easy way
uh well it would mean that we could
avoid paramodulation
uh which would make the code a bit
cleaner but i don't that's really not
the bottleneck
i mean like efficiency wise but is it
but
in terms of the presentation of a proof
is it relevant
um somewhat
if yeah i mean it would change it would
mean that we
no longer had to okay well okay here's
one
obvious way we could perhaps improve the
understandability of the proofs
right in a proof object we make a
distinction between the construct and
the rule
right where we say uh we say construct
you know axiom three rule
pattern goes to literal or something
right yes uh
if we had a way of handling two-way
patterns in a consistent way we wouldn't
have to make that distinction
because the construct itself could be a
two-pack you know two-way pattern rule
in which case the patterns and the rule
the constructs and the rules are the
same thing
um i guess that's that's something we
could change potentially right i mean
see one of the things that's really
weird here is that the proof objects
that we are generating from finding
equation of proof are not that different
from the things that we would want to
generate i mean they're almost like
sparkle
sequences and they're you know there are
a lot of things that are very similar
here
there is a grand unification of all of
this that is
yeah that
basically the way to think about this
and maybe this is what you're trying to
say and i'm not yet understanding it
is you know normal computation like a
turing machine
is you know you're following a path
we've got this non-deterministic
computation
that is you know represented by this
multi-way graph and now we're trying to
understand things in terms of
non-deterministic computation
which is indeed you know this has been
my last month of um
of kind of how to think about
non-deterministic computation
maybe we should maybe we should take
that up in a few minutes
and um uh um
uh fair enough um
all right so we will continue uh live
stream in about 10 minutes
on our physics project and i need to get
some lunch otherwise i'm going to become
completely incoherent
so thanks everybody who's been in this
meeting and thank you
folks on the live stream